[موسيقى]
صرخه امهات حمله اطلقتها اخيرا امهات وعدد
من الشهداء لا يطلب من الكثير فقط استرداد
جثامين ابنائهن الشهداء من اثر الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الذي يبقيها ولسان في ثلاجات
او في مقابر بلا شواهد تحمل ارقاما عوضا
عن اسماء ساكنيها اكثر من 370 شهيدا
فلسطينيه من بينهم اطفال تحتجز اسرائيل
جثامنهم في ثلاجات او في مقابر ارقام منذ
عام 2015 اخر الشهداء المحتجزه جثامنهم هو
الاسير ناصر ابو حميد المخيم الامعري في
رام الله الذي استشهد الشهر الماضي الا ان
تاريخ مقابر الارقام من ذلك فهي رافقت
اسرائيل منذ تاسيسها ويبدو انما كشف منها
ليست والقليل وهي تحوي ايضا جثامين لشهداء
العرب واردت اسرائيل منها ان يكون الموت
بدايه معاناه واداه انتقام وعقابا لاسررهم
وشعبهم وورقه للتفاوض والمساومه في انتهاك
للقيم الانسانيه والقوانين الدوليه في
قصتنا الليله مقابل الارقام يقتفي فريقنا
اثر هذه المقابر التي يفرض عليها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والسيتارا من السريه والكتمان
فلم تنجح محاولاتنا التوصل والتواصل مع
قياده الجيش الاسرائيلي لطلب اذن تصوير في
هذه المقابر تكرر الامر مع عهد ابو كبير
الاسرائيلي للطب الشرعي حيث تشرحوا وتحفظ
جثث الشهداء وفيه تتواتر شهادات عن انتزاع
اعضاء من اجساد الشهداء تتبعنا مسار
استرداد جثمان مشهوره العروري بعد احتجاز
دام اربعه وثلاثين عاما كاول جثمان اجري
تحريره من قبضه الاحتلال والثقنا لحظات
استلام والدي الشهيد يوسف ابو جزر
انا بعد ثلاث سنوات من احتزازه من قبل
الاحتلال في ثلاجه رفقنا والده الشهيد
الاسير عبد الحميد ابو سرور وهي تطالب فقط
بحقها في زياره قبر لابنها الذي تقول
السلطات الاسرائيليه انه مدفون في مقبره
عام عاد قرب طبريه شديده التحصين واين
يمنع الاقتراب منها وفشلت محاولاتنا
لتصوير اما بقيه هذه القصه المؤلمه
فنستكملها مع ضيفينا عصام العروري ممثل
الحمله الوطنيه للسرداد جثامين الشهداء
ومدير مركز القدس للمساعدات القانونيه
وكريستويل رئيس مجلس التفاهم العربيه
البريطاني وكذا ممثلين لاسر شهداء تحتاج
اسرائيل جثامنهم
نساله ضيوفنا الكرام عن تفاصيل معاناه اسر
الشهداء في استرداد جثامين ابنائها وعن
الجهود الجاريه لتسليط الضوء على هذا
الملف الانساني وكيف ينظر القانون الدولي
الى هذا النهج الاسرائيلي وسبل التحقق
القانوني من الشهادات المتواتره عن انتزاع
اجساد او اجزاء من اجساد الشهداء ومحاسبه
المسؤولين عن هذا الفرق لكن نشاهد القصه
ثم نبدا الحوار
جريمه الشهداء منذ بدايه احتلال الاراضي
الفلسطينيه في عام 48
طفل يعني طفل يعني 15 و 8 شهور يعني شو
اجورهم الي ارتكبوا يعني عشان انت تحتاج
الجثمان مثلا
ده لا يعني احتجاز
جسم هناك ملفات لمفقودين ايضا تعامل
معامله الملفات الجثامين المحتجزه بمعنى
ان هناك مفقودين المناطق التي فقد فيها
اشخاص المسؤول عنها عسكريه في وقتها كان
السلطات الاحتلال
بحث عن الشهداء المعتقلين لدى اسرائيل في
طريق يحاول فيها اهل الشهداء الفلسطينيين
لما شمل عائلاتهم واستعاده جثامين ابنائهم
فهذه الصور هي كل ما تبقى للعائلات من
ابنائهم
بكيفضح التعنتيل الاسرائيلي لكي طقم معهم
مبادل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
الشهداء
[موسيقى]
من الشهداء الفلسطينيين في الثلاجات او في
مقابر سريه تسمى مقابر الارقام
هنا تنتشر لوحات معدنيه تحمل ارقاما
مختلفه محاطه باسلاك شائكه وابواب محروسه
يمنع الدخول اليها وتعتبر مناطق عسكريه
مغلقه هذه المقابر هي مدافن بسيطه بدون
شواهد ومثبت فوق القبر لوحه المعدنيه تحمل
رقما معينا ولهذا سميت بمقابر الارقام فهي
تتخذ الارقام بديلا لاسماء الشهداء
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عندما يقوم بدفن هذه
الجثثامين في مقابر الارقام يقوم بدفنها
بدون تحديد هويه المدفون داخل هذا القبر
وقد يدفن اكثر من جثمان بنفس القدر وللاسف
الشديد لا يوجد بنك لا يوجد فحوصات لا
يوجد هويه لصاحب القبر
كوشي في النقابه عن اربع مقابر رئيسيه وهي
مقبره الارقام المجاوره لجسر بنات يعقوب
وتقع في منطقه عسكريه عند ملتقى الحدود
الاسرائيليه السوريه اللبنانيه شماليه
بحيره طبريا تم تاسيسها عام
1982 وتضم ما يقارب 500 قبر
مقبره تسمى مقبره لضحايا العدوه تقع في
المنطقه العسكريه المغلقه ما بين مدينه
اريحا وجسر دانيه في غور الاردن
1967 ويوجد بها حوالي 100 قمر
تاسيسها بعد حرب
1973 ولم يعرف عدد القبول في داخلها
المقبره مقبره الشيطان وتقع في قريه وادي
الحمام شمالي مدينه طبريه بها حوالي 350
جثمانا شهداء معارك منطقه الاغوار بين
عامي
1965 و 1975
تتطاير على الارض بشكل واضح مغطاه باكياس
بلاستيكيه بدون علامات ويبدو انها اقتلعت
من مكانها
وعندما
بسبب المطر
[موسيقى]
رافقنا عصام العاروري مؤسس الحمله الشعبيه
لاسترداد الجاذبين الشهداء الفلسطينيين
والعرب للبحث في مصير الشهداء المحتجزين
في هذه المقبره وفي العاشر من اغسطس عام
2010 دفن اول جثمان تم استرداده من
اسرائيل جثمان بن عمه مشهور عروري بعد
احتجاز دام 34 عاما
تم فتح اول مره القبر اللي كان حسب
سجلاتهم هذا قبر مشهور ولم يكن فيه تبين
انه فارغ وممكن يكون كان في جثمان شهيد
ونهشته همم الوحوش وفي المره الثالثه
تاكدوا ان هذا هذا جثمان الشهيد المشهور
تم اجراء فحص الديانه ثلاث مرات في المره
الثالثه ابلغونا من تاكدهم ان هذا هو
جثمان مشهور
[موسيقى]
توجهنا الى مقر الحمله الوطنيه لاسترداد
جثامين شهداء الفلسطينيين في مدينه رام
الله
بدانا البحث عن ملفات وارشيف يتعلق ببصير
المفقودين الفلسطينيين ومن ضمن الملفات
التي استوقفتنا ملف انيس دوله الذي استشهد
داخل سجون الاحتلال الاسرائيلي واختفى
جثمانه منذ ذلك التاريخ عام 1980
[موسيقى]
واحنا نحن توجهنا المحكمه العليا في هذا
الملف وكان الرد بانهم استنفذوا الاجراءات
للبحث عن جثمان انيس
[موسيقى]
قميص نادي الدوريه بعد معركه الكرامه
نقضوا عمليه على مقر الحكم العسكري
وطلبوا بعض الناس وبعض الناس اعترفوا
عليهم على الدوريه وشعره بالتقدم وجرش
اشتباك غط انسحاب المجموعه المجموعه غادرت
باتجاه الاردن وان انجرح بيجروا وقع اسير
تعتمد اسرائيل على انظمه الاحتلال
البريطانيه التي سنت في العام
1945 والتي خولت الجيش صلاحيه احتجاز
جسمين الفلسطينيين لاستخدامها لاحقا على
ما يبدو في مفاوضات تبادل اسرى مستقبليه
في البدايه كان هناك قرار المجلس الوزان
المظاهر الكابينات بعدم اطلاق سراح
الجاثامين واستخدامهم كورت الضغط ومفاوضات
مع حركه حماس في 2018 صدر قرار من محكمه
العدل العليا بعدم صحه قرار الكبينات
واعطى الحكومه
والكنيست اسمه فرصه ست شهور لنص قانون او
وضع قانون صريح ومباشر يسمح بذلك بال 2019
صدى القرار من المحكمه العليا بالسماح
باحتجاز جاسمين الشهداء بناء على شروط
قرار الالكانات في ال 2017 في ال همم 2020
قام الكبينات او مجلس الوزان المصغر بوضع
قرار جديد
بتساوي كافه الشهداء او الجثامين الشهداء
بالسماح للاحتلال باحتجاز اي جثمان بغض
النظر عن تبعيته السياسيه صور لحماس او
الايجار اخرى او حتى لا يوجد لدي اي
تماسياسي او قد يكون قتل بالخطا والتهمه
بانه قام بعمليه سيتم احتجاز
هنا في مخيم عايده شمال مدينه بيت لحم
[موسيقى]
تتوجه ازهار والده الشهيد عبد الحميد ابو
سرور الى قبر نجلها المفتوح في مقبره
المخيم
انا شو بعرفني انه ابني استشهد ممكن ابني
يكون حي يعني انا ما هون موجود قبر مفتوح
لكن ابني موجود في مكان اخر وابني اسير
اسير شهيد من حقه اني اروح ازور قبر ابني
حتى لو انها منطقه امنيه منطقه فش مشكله
السجن منطقه امنيه
واهالي الاسرى بروحوا يزوره ابناءهم وانا
من حقي اني ازور قبر ابني وهذا اخر كان
مطلب
احنا عم نرافق ومن متى القانونيه عيله
الشهيد عبد الحميد ابو سرور بكل موضوع
المبدا تبع احتجاز الجثمان اللي للاسف
يعني
المحكمه رافضه الالتماس ولحد ما يكون في
عن الوضعيه يبدا تكون انه لحد ما تكون في
صفقه الشهيد رحيضل اذن الجيش المحتجز مع
الجيش الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
مع قياده الجيش الاسرائيلي لطلب اذن تصوير
في مقابر الارقام ولكن كل محاولاتنا في
التواصل عبر الايميل او عبر الهاتف
الجزيره
احكي معي الناطقه بيسان الجيش
مرحبا ايلا هذا في مسؤوليه الجيش مع مين
ممكن نحكي اذا بدنا مقابل
مش الجيش نفسه
توجد مقبره للارقام تم تاسيسها في العام
2001 كما ورد في تقرير جريده معاريف حول
مقابر الارقام في العام 2014 تحت عنوان
مقابر جثث المغربيه
هي المقبره الوحيده التي تعمل حاليا ونقيل
حوالي 300 جثمان اليها من مقبرتي جسر ادم
في غور الاردن وجسري بنات يعقوب بعد
اغلاقهما
دخلنا من البوابه الرئيسيه للمعسكر الذي
يعتبر منطقه عسكريه مغلقه والذي يقودنا
الى المقبره لكن تم منعنا من الدخول اليها
قلت له هاي منطقه عسكريه
وتوجهنا للبحث عن طرق بديله
[موسيقى]
دخلنا الى طريق الالتفافي يقودنا الى
المقبره
توجهنا وكلنا امل للوصول الى القبر رقم
141 وهو قبر عبد الحميد ابو سرور وما
انقاربنا الى الوصول حتى لحقتنا سياره
تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي ومنعتنا من
التصوير
[موسيقى]
كان اللافت في طريق عودتنا ان مقبره شحيط
الواقعه على بعد 20 كم فقط من مقبره عمي
عاد ليست تحت ايه قيود امنيه وهي التي
تحوي مقابر ارقام لجثامين مقاتلين معارك
منطقه الاغوار بين عامي
1965 و
1975 ووفقا لاهالي قريه وادي الحمام
فاصحاب هذه الجثامين مجهول الاسماء
والهويه
[موسيقى]
وصلنا الى شارع بن سيفي في تل ابيب حيث
معهد ابو كبير للطب الشرعي الاسرائيلي وهو
المكان الذي يتم فيه احتجاز الجثامين
الشهداء الفلسطينيين في الثلاجات وتشريح
جثامينهم في بعض الاحياء
[موسيقى]
مره يقف ريدمان
لاجراء مقابله مع طبيب او متحدث مسؤول
للبحث عن اجوبه حول ظروف الشهداء هنا لكن
دون جدوى
[موسيقى]
النمط السائد كان هو ان يتم احتجاز
الجثمان لايام ومن ثم يتم تسليمه
وبررت السلطات العسكريه الاسرائيليه ذلك
لانه بتم الاحتجاز لمعرفه سبب الوفاه
واجراء التشريح طب لماذا لا يكون هناك
مندوب عن العائله لحضور التشريح هذا الحكي
كان في اوائل 89
[موسيقى]
من وفاته يعني في لبس بالقصه
زملا ان يسبقوا له انه ما تم اسعاره حملته
انا بنفسي الى العياده السجن وكان معي
شبين قاعدين بركضوا معي هناك كويس لكن كان
في تباطؤ في الارسال الى المستشفى واقول
لم يرسل الى المستشفى ممكن اخذه اعضائه
وممكن انه باعه جثته للجامعه والا اين
جثته هل انه اخذوا اجزاء نعم على الاقل
انا شفت محل العين في قطنه يعني انا اجزم
انه انه صار انه اخذه اعضاء لكن التبرير
كان انه احنا بناخذها كعيه يجب ان تحفظ
حسب القانون وكذا انها هل كانت تستخدم لكن
اليهود هذه نفسه اعلم انه تم الاستفتاء
[موسيقى]
في العام 2012 بدا الفلسطينيون يرون بصيص
الامل اذ اخرجت اسرائيل عن 91 شهيدا
فلسطينيه كانت تحتاج ظرفاتهم في مقبره
الارقام بغور الاردن منذ سنوات
هنا في مدينه رفح في قطاع غزه قصص اخرى
[موسيقى]
عن الشهيد يوسف ابو جزر والذي كان محتجزا
في ثلاجات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
لحظات وصور الشهيد يوسف جاسر ابو جزر
لكن الحمد لله اليوم تاكدنا انه مستشهد
والحمد لله رب العالمين ربنا يرتقي مع
الشهداء ان شاء الله
فكان متجمد بالكامل الى السواد طبعا من
الثلج من كثر التلج انت عارف الثلج ما هو
بسبب حروف في البشر بس انا يعني
اللي حاس في نفس الموضوع يعني الاستهتار
استخدامه في في الاسعافات الاوليه وكيف
بتعاملوا معي انا بتعاملوش
التنفس تبع الاسعافات الاوليه
الاسعافات منه
[موسيقى]
اطفال من ضمنهم الشهيد يوسف ابو جزر لم
نكن نتلقى او لم نستلم رد نهائي من طلع
السلطات الاحتلال بانهم يريدون التحفظ على
الجثمان بغرض التفاوض مع حركه حماس
الموت نهايه لكل شيء في الطبيعه
لكن هنا ليس كذلك
فحتى الجثامين تتعرض لعقوبه الاعتقال
ويحرم الاهل في غمره حزنهم من اشياء
مالوفه وبسيطه كالقاء النظره الاخيره
[موسيقى]
بقر
دي
[موسيقى]
حيا او حتى ميتا وشهدا نرحب بكم
العروري ممثل الحمله الوطنيه
الشهداء ومدير مركز القدس للمساعدات
القانونيه وام ناصر ابو حميد وهي والده
الشهيد الاسير ناصر ابو حميد وهي توصف
بانها سنديانه فلسطين لها اربعه من
ابناءها اسرى في المعتقلات الاسرائيليه
كما استشهد ابنها عبد المنعم ابو حميد عام
1990 ومعنا من قريه مادم جنوب نابلس محمد
نصار وهو والد الشهيد شادي نصار ينضم
الينا من لندن رئيس مجلس اتفاهم العربي
البريطاني لعلنا نبدا معك ام ناصر على
الوفق في ايجاد السؤال امام قصتك التي
تبدو استثنائيه بالفعل نصر محمد شريف
واسلام
ابناءك الاربعه في
سجون الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وهو اسرع
وابنك عبد المنعم استشهد سنه 1994 كما
استشهد الشهر الماضي فقط ناصر وذلك بعد
معاناته للاسف الشديد في سجون الاحتلال
والذي كان مصابا بسرطان في الرئه نود ان
ان تمكنت من ايجاد الكلمات ان تشرحين لنا
ما الذي يمثله ذلك بالنسبه لك كام
اول شيء تحياتي لكم اهلا وسهلا الاخوه
اربعه صح معكم مين مدى الحياه بس كمان
جهاد قبل اسبوعين كسروا الباب علينا
ودخلوا اخذوا الخامس حكموا اداري
ايه بالنسبه لك قصه ناصر ابلغونا انه ناصر
يستشهد ما بلغونا انه ناصر استشهد ولا
اعطونا شهاده وفاه نحنا طلبنا يعني عن
طريق محامي انه حدا من العيله يتعرف على
جثه ناصر ونشوفه يتاكد انه هذا اخو ناصر
حتى يصلي عليه زي ما بنصلي على المسلمين
وعلى على حدا بس للاسف للاسف هم ردوا يعني
ناصر مش اول شيء زي ما حكيتي يعني يعني
هاي معناه معناه يعني لاهل الشهداء عندهم
شهدائنا مش ارقام هذول لازم يندفنوا في
مقابر المسلمين في فلسطين اللي ضحك وناظره
مشانها مش عشان يحتاج ويحطهم عنده احنا
بدنا اولادنا احنا لما بندافع
عن كرامتهم عن حقهم عن شعبه عن مقدساتهم
هم لما بيروح منهم واحد بقيم الدنيا
فاحنا اولادنا بغض النظر هم اولادهم
يعني لما واحد من بنك بيكون على ظهر دبابه
بكون يكسب الاطفال من النساء وشيوخ احنا
اولادنا ما عملوا هيك اولاد ده ضحوا نادر
مش انا الارض مشان فلسطين مشان الشعب
الفلسطيني مش عشان يستشهدوا جوه السجن
وياخذنا الاحتلال يحتجزوا ما عنده يعني
لن نقدر ذلك يعني ان يستشهد احد ان ذلك او
اثنانهما الان المستشدين وخمسه في العصر
هذه ماساه لكن ان يتم احتياج جثمانه ولا
تتمكنين من دفنه يعني ما هو شعورك ما الذي
يمثله بالنسبه لك هل تمكنتي اصلا من رؤيته
عندما كان في همم السجون في سجن الاحتلال
اسيرا وقد كان مريضا كما ذكرنا همم
بعد ما برد كنا نشوف بس للاسف يعني على
كرسي متحركه اخر
خلونا نزوره العائله طالبه طلبوا يعني
عملنا عن طريق المحامي رح نزلناه على 11
بالليل عندهم بالمستشفى اكيد ناصر كان
يحتضر يعني وكان كل دوله اسرائيل على راس
ناصر ناصر على الاجهزه لا حول ولا قوه بعد
ساعتين اتصلت عليهم ما بعرفش كيف عرفنا
نادي الاسير بلغنا انه ناصر استشهدوا هم
ما يبلغونا انه ناصر يستشهد يعني معي انا
ومعانا يعني استشهد يعني الحمد لله روح
عند رب العالمين بس احنا بدنا اولادنا
لامتى نضل ساكتين بدنا اولاد بدنا نشوفهم
بدنا احنا يعني ولا ايه يودعوهم احفادهم
ما بيعرفوهن بدون
مقابل المسلمين بنصلي عليهم يعني لمتى
بتفضلوا لاولادنا احنا مش لازم نسكت عليهم
تحول الى السيد محمد نصار وهو ابو شادي
والد الشهيد شادي نصار من بين ما وصف به
شاديه ابو شادي انه كان صامتا صامدا عنيدا
في مواجهه المحتل لكنه استشهد
ان نعرف عمليه احتجاز جثمانه في ايه ظروف
تمت وما الذي تمثله لكم انتم كالاسره كاهل
كخوه كام
همم بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع
اول شيء اهلا وسهلا فيكم تحياتي لكم
احنا بالنسبه لشادي كامل هو العمود الفقري
للبيت عندي كنت انا شغال انا واياه ايدي
وايدي في البنيان
وتعرض للظروف
قاسيه لما اني انا طلعت عمره في 2001
اجى عليه الجيش وهو يعزل في الارض
مش طبيعي يعجب فيه
صار عند شادي
نظره غير شكل للجيش وللالاحتلال
فكان امنياته انه يتحرر من
الاحتلال ويغير شيء في الواقع الدنيا هون
لكن للاسف استشهد واختار طريقه الله يرحمه
و هيو من ال 2002 من 7000 2002
وانا حتى صار عندي شك انه شادي ما استشهد
لانه ما اجانا اي خبر يقين من قبل
الاحتلال او من قبل اي مؤسسه رسميه انه
شادي استشهد
علشان هيك عنده الواحد صار شك انا كابو
عندي شك انه شادي ما استشهد محتجز
فبدنا اثبات انه يبين انه شادي مستشهد
الله يرحمه
وثاني شيء نحن من طالب انه نزور قبره
يعني صار عمرنا في ال 64 يعني شو ضل من
العمر
مناطق عسكريه مغلقه ولا يجوز الاقتراب
منها وحاول فريقنا في الواقع الاقتراب
للتصوير لكننا لم نتمكن من ذلك ما تبعنا
في الفيلم يعني يتحول السيد عصام العروري
وسعود اليك ابو شادي سيد عصام يعني ثم عن
اسرائيل في الاذيه في التنكيل
بالاسرائيليه بالفلسطيني حيا وبيتا اسيرا
مريضا يعني بكل الطرق وشتى المجالات انت
شخصيا رئيس هذه
الحمله الوطنيه للاسترداد جثامين الشهداء
لكن لديك قصه خاصه ايضا تابعناها في
الفيلم عن ابن عمك همم الشهيد الذي
استدعى جثمانه بعد 30 عاما
نتحدث حقيقه عن ارقام عديده لكن لا توجد
احصائيات رسميه بدا ربما موضوع التوثيق من
سنه 2015 لك الموضوع قديم قدم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ما الذي تقوله الاحصائيات
لديكم فيما يخص هذه القضيه
مساء الخير
لاهالي الشهداء لام ناصر وابو شادي واهالي
الشهداء الاخرين الذين يشاهدوننا
وفي واقع الحال منذ بدات الحمله الوطنيه
لاسترداد جثامين الشهداء في نهائيات عام
2007 وبدايه 2008
وحتى وحتى تاريخه وثقت اكثر من 990 حاله
احتجاز لجامين شهداء تم تحرير همم قسم
كبير منهم على دفعات ومجموع ما تم تحريره
في اوقات
مختلفه من مقابل الارقام يزيد عن 370
شهيدا وشهيدا وهناك حوالي 250 شهيده ممن
ادعوا في الثلاجات لفترات محدوده ثم جرى
تحريرهم في الفتره بين 2015 وحتى تاريخه
وكما ذكرتم في التقرير فان المحتجزين
حاليا
الموثق الحالات الموثقه هو من 300
شهيدا اضافه الى 76
بمعنى لا تعلم عائلاتهم ان كانوا شهداء
احياء ولا يوجد اي اثبات اا على استشهادهم
حتى حتى ااه من هناك شكوك انه موجود في
مقابر الارقام لا توجد اي شهاده وفاه بحق
اي منهم ونحن نعلم همم ان من طبيعه البشر
حتى حين نسمع عن حادث السير واا تاذى احد
الاقارب او الاصدقاء يبقى لدينا امل داخلي
طالما لم نشاهد الجثمان انه ربما وقع خطا
وهناك حالات تعايشناها اذكر في احدى
المرات في عام 2012
والده الشهيد حسن ابو زيد من قباطيه جرى
تحرير جثمان وبعد احتجاجه سبع سنوات ذكر
لنا والد الشهيد بعد دفنه في ليله الدفنه
لاول مره ام الشهيد نامت ليله كامله لانها
كانت تصحوا في كل ليله مفزوعه ان ابنها
على صراخ ابنها
عدى في مكان ما هذا هو معاناه مستمره
مضاعف اضافه للاستشهاد اضافه يعني ولذلك
صحيح صحيح
لمقاومه التعذيب في الامم المتحده ان
احتجاز الجثامين يرقى الى مستوى التعذيب
لانه تعذيب للاحياء وليس للشهداء ممتاز
هذه النقطه هتعطيني اياها تحول بها لضيفنا
من لندن السيد كنيس دايلا رئيس مجلس تفاهم
العربي البريطاني سيده الى اين ما تستمع
الى هذه الشهادات حتى من المسؤولين على
هذه الحمله هي كانت لا يخلوا بيت او اسره
في فلسطين من مثل هذه الممارسات للاحتلال
الاسرائيليه التي يمنعن فعلا في اذيه
الفلسطيني ما الذي تقوله القوانين الدوليه
فيما يخص هذه القضيه تحديدا
واو فاست 4 اولا شكرا جزيلا لاستضافتي
وكذلك بالنسبه لي
لامهات واباء من يتحدثون هنا هذه القصص
التي تدمي قلوبنا لا تتعلق فقط بفقدانهم
لاحبائهم ولم تعطى لهم الفرصه
لنهو ويصل الى النقطه نهايه قصتهم القانون
الدولي هو واضح ان اطراف النزاع لا بد ان
تحترم
الاموات لابد ان يحضر الميت
بفرصه
ان يحضر
همم
عند عمليتي الدفنه اذا الطريقه التي نراها
هي تعتبر انتهاك لحقوق الموتى ولك ان
تتخيل مان يمارسونه بحقي الاحياء هذه ربما
تعتبر بمثابه ورقه المساومه في المستقبل
او ربما قد تستخدم هذه الممارسات
لمعاقبتي والانتقام من اسرها الذين
تعتبر نوع من التعذيب النفسيه لهؤلاء
الاشخاص عندما تكون الاسره لا تعرف ما حدث
لابنها هذه الامور هي تعتبر وحشيه وتتخطى
حتى بامكان العقل ان يتصور اذا هذه تعتبر
نوع من سياسه دوله واضحه تم النظر في هذه
القضايا على مستوى المحاكم الدولي المحكمه
العليا
ما حدث من خلال هذه النظره
العنصريه اذا لابد ان نقول اننا راينا
مجموعات قامت بذلك حماس قامت بنفس الشيء
لكن على مستوى صغير جدا وكل الاطراف اطراف
النزاع لابد ان تحترمه الموت لابد ان تعيد
جثامنهم من اجل ان يحضوا بتقوص الدفن
المطلوبه
القوانين توجد الاذنات موجوده مجلس الامن
لطالما اصدرها العديد من القرارات ضد
اسرائيل لكن دائما تبقى مساله التطبيق
والافلات من العقاب كيف يمكن وضع قوات
الاحتلال امام مسؤولياتها باعتقادك في اي
اتجاه يجدر العمل وعلى اي مستوى
هذا الامر هو صعب للغايه في الوقت الذي
تتمتع فيه اسرائيل
بالدعم الكامل للقوى العظمى مثل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
والقوه العظمى في اوروبا مثل المانيا
وبريطانيا بلدي هذه الدول سماحه بان يكون
هناك هذا المشهد الذي فيه افلات من العقاب
كذلك فيه حق بناء المستوطنات وكذلك تطهير
عراقي في بعض المناطق
واحداث حالات عقاب بالنسبه لاشخاص يعيشون
في غزه هذه كلها تعتبر جرائم لذلك لهم
الحق بان تتم الاحاله الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه ان يتم او تتم المساءله
بالنسبه للقاده الاسرائيليين هذه المساله
هي محبطه بنسبه الفلسطينيين لانهم لا يرون
اي افق هذا يعتبر فشل بالنسبه للمجتمع
الدولي للايفائي بمتطلبات القوانين
الدوليه هم مستعدون للقيام بذلك في حاله
اوكرانيا وليس في حاله فلسطين
وعندما اتحدث الى الكثير من الاشخاص في
مناطق مختلفه من العالم اتحدث اليهم عن
ازدواجيه المعايير اتحدث عن النفاق الذي
تمارسها هذه الدول وحلفاء هذه الدول
بمكيالين فقط يعني هذه الدول للاسف الشديد
ابانت عن
وجه يعني همم
يعني يضع الامور في نصابها بان الكيس
بمكان فقط لكن اكثر من مكيال على حسب
الدوله على حسب الشعب الذي
يمارس ضده اي نوع من ال- ال- الامور
السلبيه يعني احد اعود مره اخرى عفوا
السيده ام ناصر يعني في هذا الموضوع
بالذات المتعلق بتحركات القانونيه هل قمتم
انتم باي تحركات قانونيه على مستوى محلي
خاصه عندما نعلم بان السلطه الفلسطينيه قد
ادانت هذا همم الموضوع همم واحتجاز ابنكم
الشهيد ناصر همم ابو حميد هل تلقيتم ايت
وعود بالضغط على اسرائيل ما الذي تم في
هذا الخصوص ام ناصر
والله بنسمع كلها وعود وعود من السلطه من
غير السلطه احنا رفعنا للمحكمه العليا
للجنايات لغيرته كلها وحيد لا تاريخ مرض
ناصر من سنه واحنا نعاني نعاني على الاقل
وناطر
بس لحياتنا دي ما حدا ما حدا بلغنا ولا اي
شيء
واحنا يا عمي الحمد لله رب العالمين بس
احنا بدنا يعني ابني لما مرض من عندهم من
وين من عندهم ما قال ج مريض الا لما
يعرفوه على الاخر احنا بدنا اولادنا بدنا
اولادنا باي طريقه
اقسم بالله العظيم انا الثلاجه اللي في
الدار ما بافتحها كل واحده بتحفظ ذكر الله
اكثر من المعاناه هذه والله ما بفتحها
يعني شو بدك اكثر من هالمعناه هذه يعني
واضح جدا ومفهوم السيده ام ناصر ما ذكرتي
فيما يخص موضوع الثلاجه كان الله في عونك
حقيقه سنديانه فلسطين وكل امهات
الفلسطينيات لما يقدمونهم من تضحيه نيابه
عن الامه العربيه والاسلاميه جميعا اعود
اليك سيد ابو شادي يعني بالنسبه لكم هل من
تحركات قانونيه وهل تجدون بانه يمكن ان
يكون لها اي جدول باعتقادكم لتحريك هذا
الموضوع خاصه فيما يخص الموضوع ابنكم ما
الذي قمتم به من اجل استرداد الجثمان من
سلطات الاحتلال
يعني ما خليناش ولا اي مؤسسه حقوقيه اي
مركز يتواصل مع حقوق الانسان مع الصليب مع
اي مؤسسه بتعتني في هذا الموضوع الا رفعنا
لها القضيه هذه وما في اي تجاوب يعني ما
حتى المؤسسات والكليات وما في اي تجاوب
بقول لك ما في منه ما في منه يعني ما
خلوناش اي امل على انه انسان
بنطلب من السلطه يعني هي الممثل الوحيد
للشعب الفلسطيني لانهم يساعده اهالي
الشهداء يوقفوا معاهم في هذا الموضوع
لانه هذا موضوع حساس للكل يعني الكل
الفلسطيني
لكن قوه الاحتلال تمارس ذلك وتقوم به
المحكمه العليا اجازه عمليه احتجاز
الجثامين ما الاسانيد القانونيه التي
اعتمدت عليها لتبرير ذلك وجعله يعاني منه
الفلسطينيون
تغير تغير الموقف السياسي والقانون
الاسرائيلي على مر السنين
ولكن اخر ما تفتك عنه اييي
ذهن العنصريه
انه جرى تعديل قانون ما يسمى مكافحه
الارهاب التعديل رقم 3 الذي اجاز
لقوى الامن الاسرائيليه ان تحتجز اي جثمان
لاسباب امنيه دون تفصيل ودون رقابه من اي
جهه قضائيه وبالتالي يكفي ااا تبرير
احتجاج الجثمان
بالامن الذي اصبح بقره مقدسه همم
وجنوحها اكثر فاكثر محوريه المتطرف
وكل وكل وزير دفاع جديد ياتي ويشمر عن
ذراعه ليبدو اكثر تطرفا كان هناك جلسه
مقرره في 26 واحد للنظر في مجموعه من
الجثامين منهم شادي جثمان الشهيد شادي ابن
ابو شادي وبلغنا اليوم تاجيل هذه الجلسه
حتى 13 من اذار حتى يستطيع وزير الدفاع
الجديد تسلم مهامو وكاننا نتعامل مع اشخاص
وكل شخص علينا ان نبدا معه من جديد وان
كنا لا نتوقع الكثير ولذلك همم فانه
سوى من تدوير هذه القضيه لان موقف سلطات
الاحتلال فيها ليس فقط لا سند قانوني له
هذا يمثل سقوطا سياسيا واخلاقيا لا توجد
دوله في العالم ولا حتى عصابه تحت تجزامين
وتساهم عليها من بينهم 12 طفلا ومن بينهم
نساء جثامنهم محتجاتها في الثلاجات هناك
هناك اسرع 10 اسرى استشهدوا في الاثر همم
اقدمهم الشهيد انيس دول الذي تحدث شقيقه
في هذا التقرير ولكن ايضا هناك همم سجين
همم الاسير فارس باروده الذي همم استشهد
بعد قضاء 27 عاما في الاثر كانت عائلته
وتنتظر ان تراه حيا ولكنها تحرم حتى من
رؤيته ميته همم هذا ما يسمى في علم
الاجتماع السياسي همم
بالتعبير الغربي نكروبوليتكس وهو سياسات
الدفن والسيطره على الجسد كان مفهوم
استعماله وامتدادا للعنصريه التي لا ترى
في الاخر بشرا تجرده من انسانيه بان تمنحه
الرقم
وتجرده من انسانيته حين تحوله الى سلعه
للمبادله تجرده من انسانيته حين تدعيه
فقدان وكانه شيء وليس انسان هذه الحالات
التي تنبئ بجوهر عنصريه لسياسات هذا
الاحتلال همم
بعدم التوقف
وعدم الاستسلام امام هذا الواقع لاننا في
موقف اخلاقي نمثل التفوق الاخلاقي على هذه
العنصريه
ونحن واثقون اننا في يوم ما سوف تنتصر
عظام الشهداء واشلائهم على هذه الغطرسه
ولكن املونا ان نقصر الفتره
خصوا انه هناك اباء وامهات ماتوا غدروا
دنيانا وكانت حسرته واهميتهم الاخيره قبل
الموت ان يدفنوا احبائهم لا نريد ان همم
نفقد مزيدا من الاحباب من الاحباء ولا
تريد ان نفقد مزيدا من الاباء والامهات
اسرائيليه تتحدث عن وجود معارضه اسرائيليه
محليه داخليه لهذا همم الموضوع هناك
يعترضون على الموضوع على المستشفى
القانوني السابق الحكومه الاسرائيليه ميني
مازوز عام 2004 عارض عمليه تحويل الاحتجاز
الجيتامين الى سياسه دائمه وغير ده للاسف
كما باتت اليوم واقعا همم يعني كيف يمكن
تفسير هذه المفارقه الى المضيف في عمليه
الاحتجاز من جهه ورغم هذه المعاظه نرى انك
تراها ربما معارضه سوريه لتقول اسرائيل في
نهايه الامر انا مختلف الاراء موجوده وهي
كما ترويج لنفسها دي دوله ديمقراطيه وتسمح
باختلاف الاراء
هذا جزء من التدهور القانوني والسياسي
والاخلاق في دوله الاحتلال والذي يشمل
كافه المجالات همم اسرائيل تغرق اكثر
فاكثر في العنصريه والتطرف
وهناك ايضا تسابق على لارضاء همم لارضاء
الجمهور المتطرف
وحصد المزيد من الاصوات في الانتخابات همم
لذلك بدنا نشهد في كل معركه انتخابيه
تسبقها موجه من التطرف بحق الفلسطينيين
مصادرات استيطان قتل اكثر احتجاج جاثامين
وكل ما كان كان الحزب واكثر تطرفا وعنصريه
كلما زادت فرصه بالفوز وحزب المزيد من
المقاعد همم شهدنا هذا العام اعلى موجه من
جرائم الاعدام خارج القانون همم خلال
العقدين الاخيرين ومنذ بدات بعض المنظمات
الدوليه في توثيق استشهاد الفلسطينيين
هناك الاعدام الميدان على الهواء مباشره
سيدنا عشرات الحالات لاناس مسالمين وكثير
من الاصابات ولذلك في بعض الحالات التي
يتم تحرير فيها تحرير الجثامين تضع سلطات
الاحتلال شرطا بمنع اجراء تشريح عدلي
وتستوفي كفالات من اهالي الشهداء في حال
اجروا تشريحا للجثامين ابنائهم لماذا لا
يريدون التشريح اي جرائم يخفونها ما ذكر
والاعترافات السابقه عن التبرع ومبادله
جثامين بعض الشهداء الفلسطينيه
بعض المعدات والمايكروسكوبات التي تبرعت
بها كليات الطب لمعهد ابو كبير مقابل
سلخ سلخ جلود الشهداء بعد استشهادهم واخذ
قنيات اعينهم هذا ما هناك اعترافات ممن
مارسه همم هذه الجرائم وهمم ولذلك هذا
الملف يكبر كل يوم همم ومع كبره همم
تزداد عزيمه الشعب الفلسطيني وت بحقوقه
وبكرامته وهذا الشعب الذي هو صامد منذ 100
وعامين منذ همم منذ فرض الانتداب
الاستعمار البريطاني عليه في سنه 1921 لم
يركع همم لم يسقط على رجليه ربما مرتين من
الهدوء ولكنه يزداد تمسكا بحقوقه
بكرامته وكرامه شهدائه
كريس يعني قصه هذه همم هذه القصه قصه
قصتنا الليله جسمينا الشهداء معقده وترتبط
في الواقع اكثر من ملف اشار السيد العروضي
لموضوع انتزاع الاجساد
واستخدامها في همم دراسات او ربما لاشياء
اخرى من قبل السلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
هناك حتى شهادات متواتر من شخصيات
اسرائيليه عن انتزاع اجساد من اجساد همم
الشهداء السؤال الاول هل من اثباتاته كيف
يمكن اثبات ذلك هذا الموضوع الذي تتستر
عليه اسرائيل بشكل كبير كماضيع اخرى
وما التوصيف القانوني لهذه الممارسه وكيف
يمكن
ربما حل هذه المعضله باعتقادكم سيد
الاعضاء هذه من الامور التي تحدثت عنها
اسرائيل في التسعينيات ابن القرن الماضي
وابداعت وقالت انها لم تعد تقوم بذلك
نتزال انك اتهامات هناك بعض الاشخاص الذين
يقولون ان المساله هي مستمره على الرغم من
انه من الصعوبه مكانا نثبت ذلك وان نعرف
ان هذا الامر يحدث حقيقه في غياب وجود
الجسمي لا نعرف في حال ما اذا كان هناك اي
انتهاكات قد حدثت بشان هذه همم الجسميين
من اجل معرفه القضيه حقيقه وتصليط الضوء
على ما حدث حقيقي اسرائيل
دائما كانت تقوم بازدراء القانون الدولي
ازدراء حياه الفلسطينيين ولابد ان يتم
تسليط الضوء بدل الامر دوليا لابد من شرح
هذه المسائل بشكل جديد هناك الكثير من
الاشخاص الذين سيصدمون الى اي مدى هذه
الممارسه ممارسه احتجاز الجذابين هي
ممارسه مستمره اذن الفلسطينيون يريدون ان
يرون نهايه الاستيطان نهايه قتل
الفلسطينيين ولقد
رايتهم
تماما اشكرك السيد كريستويل
العربي البريطاني من لندن كما اشكر جزيل
الشكر سيد عصام العروري ممثل الحمله
الوطنيه لاسترداد الجثثامين الشهداء واشكر
السيد محمد نصار والد الشهيد شادي نصار
كما اشكر جزيل الشكر سنديانه فلسطين ام
ناصر ابو حميد وهي والده الشهيد الاسير
ناصر ابو حميد ختام وحلقتنا هذا من برنامج
للقصه بقيه نعود ولا نلقاكم باذن الله
الاثنين القادم او بقيه لقصه جديده السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]